we begin with this breaking news the
leaders of france germany and italy have
arrived in kiev in a show of solidarity
with ukraine the high profile visit by
italian prime minister mario draghi
french president emmanuel macron and
german chancellor olaf schultz comes
after days of speculation about a joint
visit to the ukrainian capital and as
ukraine pleads for more heavy weapons
from western countries
ukraine's forces are outmanned and
outgunned in fighting for the key city
of sivera donetsk the fierce fighting is
taking a heavy toll on civilians not
only in spiro donetsk but also in
laboring lucy shanks too
in the distance the sound of russian
shelling
for the people in the sichansk the twin
city of sevier donetsk the chance to
escape is getting smaller and smaller
ukrainian police officers drive from
house to house to find those who want to
leave but for many here it feels like
they're giving up their town
we weren't sure until it became
unbearable then i got sick
she has an endless list of illnesses and
i'm also sick
if there was a hospital here i would
have stayed here until the very last
moment
only a few kilometers away in sevier
donetsk leaving has become nearly
impossible with all the main bridges
destroyed the city is now cut off
ukraine says more than 500 civilians are
hiding inside the azad chemical factory
alongside ukrainian soldiers
moscow announced a humanitarian corridor
for the civilians but then claimed
ukrainian shelling disrupted the plan
with moscow having more manpower and
weapons it's becoming increasingly
difficult for the ukrainians to hold
their few remaining positions in the
city a russian deadline for the forces
in the chemical plan to surrender has
passed former ukrainian president
poroshenko told dw ukraine will not give
in
situation is extremely difficult and the
concentration of troops there is
enormous but our heroic soldiers is
keeping severe donetsk we
keeping the
uh azov
not as of but azod chemical plan and we
never surrender
away from the donbass russian forces
have been aiming for other high-value
targets
this footage shared by the russian
military claims to show high-precision
low-range missiles targeting a depot in
the western levee region where
ammunition for nato-supplied weapons is
stored
if true it could be russia's latest
effort to disrupt the international
supply of weapons
let's get an update now from our
correspondent roman goncharenko he joins
us from ukraine's capital kia roman the
leaders of the eu's three biggest
countries germany france and italy are
in kiev today what's the significance of
this visit
well it's hard to overestimate the
significance of this visit because uh
the three leaders of the major european
countries are visiting ukraine which is
fighting a very difficult and very
bloody war
and they were criticized before this
visit for not doing this earlier
criticized for not delivering enough
weapons to ukraine to defend itself they
were criticized for talking too much to
vladimir putin russians president of
being too soft on him so there was a lot
of pressure on all three leaders
especially in the leaders of germany and
france before this visit
if they will managed to um
to silence critics and to show the
solidarity with ukraine to say that
really standing with ukraine this
question will be solved today in a few
hours they are meeting with president
zielinski here and what is also very
important this visit is taking place at
a historic moment for ukraine ukraine
has applied
to become a candidate for eu candidacy
and in the coming days the youth summit
will decide that there is also a summit
of g7 in germany and nato summit com
nato summit coming the war in ukraine
will be on top of the agenda and the
ukrainian president also agreed to take
part in the g7 and nato summit but it's
not quite clear at the moment whether
he'll travel himself or will just be
connected via a video link
okay so a strong diplomatic show of
support from europe meanwhile the us has
announced another billion dollars in
military aid for ukraine how important
is that military aid for the country
it is extremely important and this is
what we're hearing from ukrainian
authorities every day every hour and
every minute here in kiev they are
saying that the russians the russian
artillery for example in the east of
ukraine where where there is heaviest
fighting in this war uh outnumbers the
ukrainian by 10 times and they are also
criticizing that the west has so far
delivered only 10 of the weapons
promised so ukraine is expecting more
weapons to come in the coming weeks to
be able to stop the russian advance in
the east of ukraine where the fighting
continues
there are multiple flash points in this
war what can you tell us about the
latest fighting roman
well the sir the situation remains
preaching pretty much the same as in the
past few days the the heaviest fighting
is in the city of sivara dynasty which
is an administrative used to be actually
an administrative center of the region
uh luhansk and uh ukrainian forces are
still holding the positions there and uh
the skeptics were expecting them to to
abandon the city a few weeks ago they
are still there they're still fighting
but the it is getting more and more
difficult for the ukrainian army to
resupply them with weapons and one more
problem remains it's the problem of
civilians who still stay in that city
and an attempt was made to evacuate
civilians who were hiding at a chemical
plant in several donetsk but they are
still there and that attempt was not
successful so far i think in the coming
hours and days there will be more
attempts
roman thank you very much for bringing
us up to date there that was our
correspondent roman goncharenko in kiev
let's get more now on the german
perspective on that diplomatic
initiative by three european leaders uh
our correspondent teresa trumper is with
us now she's in our parliamentary
studios here in berlin teresa why is
german chancellor olaf schultz visiting
ukraine now what's the purpose of his
trip
well that's the big question now terry
olaf schultz has previously said that he
wouldn't go to kiev just to take a photo
and so that has somewhat raised
expectations that if he does go there he
will have something to offer and that of
course could be more financial support
it could be more arms deliveries after
all ukraine's president zelensky has
criticized both germany and france and
to a lesser extent also italy of being
too slow when it comes to arms
deliveries
and of putting their own prosperity
ahead of ukraine's freedom and security
but these three could also bring good
news with regard to ukraine's bid to
become a member of the european union
because as we heard the meeting and the
visit in kiev comes just ahead of a key
meeting in brussels where the european
commission is expected to propose that
ukraine becomes a member of the block
why did it take chancellor schultz so
long to visit ukraine this visit has
been anticipated for months
oh yes uh olaf schultz was certainly
invited a lot of time since the war
broke out but back in april there was
some rift between berlin and kiev
because kiev rebuffed on very short
notice a visit by the german president
frank walter steinmeier
saying that he was too close to russia
that he made mistakes in dealing with
moscow in the past and after that olaf
schultz himself refused to go there for
a couple of weeks but that dispute was
solved in a telephone call and since
then several german politicians have
visited most notably foreign minister
analina berbock but also other ministers
the president of the german bundestag
and even the head of the biggest
opposition party and the fact that olaf
schultz himself did not go for such a
long time also caused some criticism
here in germany
so what's being said about this
diplomatic gesture here in germany
teresa
well germans are certainly watching this
visit very closely because many feel
that ukraine should get all the support
it needs but at the same time they're
also worried about what the war in
ukraine means for their own lives so i
went out to the streets of berlin to ask
people how they feel about this visit
now let's take a listen
i think it's good
he should do a lot more he doesn't do
enough
you have to help them
it's not convincing to keep saying that
ukraine has to win
but at the same time the arms deliveries
being announced are falling short of
expectations
at least for the time being
the fact that he goes there to exchange
views is basically good
he should help the people by supplying
decent weapons instead of dithering it's
dangerous i think if these three travel
there together they'll have something to
say i hope so that they don't just go
there out of decency
so quite a lot of suspense here in
germany as well when it comes to what
charles macron and draghi are exactly up
to in kiev
teresa thank you very much our
correspondent teresa tropper there
well mark montgomery is a military
expert with the foundation for defense
of democracies who served in the u.s
navy for more than 30 years and helped
to build u.s ukrainian military
relations welcome to you mark i wonder
what will this latest pledge of weapons
allow ukrainian forces to do on the
battlefield that they aren't currently
able to do
well first thank you for having me and
uh you know that is the big question and
i would say it's really more about
maintaining their ability to do what
they what they could do right now which
is you have to have these replenishment
packages flowing every few weeks if
ukrainians
of ukrainians succeed in in preventing
further russia russian encroachment
in the donbass region um they're burning
through artillery
very rapidly and they need these
replenishment packages not just from the
us but from the rest of our european
allies and partners in the contract
group
is there a chance that this war will be
decided by the outcome of battles mark
or is it going to come down as you may
suggest there down to who runs out of
money first
well you're exactly right this is a
grinding campaign so i don't think this
is about some you know mod you know some
military flair or maneuver that settles
things rapidly but it's about who can
maintain their resilience uh russia or
uh ukraine and its european and american
allies and so you know this kind of
slugfest uh requires this constant
replenishment and like i said every two
or three weeks uh with these uh with
these artillery rounds what we're
transferring here is only 36 000 rounds
they're expending 5 000 rounds a day so
this is seven days of artillery rounds
being transferred in this package
it's an incredible stat just just a
week's worth of supplies if you like it
is there a risk with that in mind that
this help as significant as it sounds
has just come too late
now i think it's it's a question of
persistence will the u.s
and its european allies show the same
resilience the ukrainian people and
their army are showing on the
battlefront well we continue to provide
these packages every few weeks you know
every two weeks from the united states
every two weeks from europe uh to bring
artillery rounds the
rocket rounds that are also included in
this package but also vehicles artillery
vehicles there's 18 in this package but
we need other ones from our european
partners and then rocket launching
systems from our european partners as
well
us army chief of staff mark milley spoke
today mark saying he thought russia had
lost somewhere between 20 and 30 of
their armored force do you believe that
to be true and does that offer hope if
so for ukraine in a war of attrition
well first i do believe it's true and i
believe you could even caveat that with
at some of their
their better equipment that was more
likely than not able to operate in other
words some of their hundred percent of
equipment is equipment that just doesn't
get out of the hangar or the uh you know
or the garage and so i really think
they've lost a significant warfighting
capacity in this uh
in this uh three you know 100 plus days
uh combat so far and if they try to
grind it out over the summer in eastern
ukraine they're going to lose another 20
to 30 percent
military expert mark montgomery thanks
so much for your time
thank you